hey this is presh talwalkar
people always email me puzzles from
social media
and they love it when i make videos
about these puzzles because it helps
them understand how to solve them and it
helps build their confidence in math
this puzzle can be described as follows
we have a three digit number represented
by a blue circle followed by a gray
circle followed by a red circle
this three digit number is added
together three times to produce another
three digit number represented by three
red circles
the challenge is to solve for each color
of each circle
it's not stated in the problem that was
distributed you can assume each color
represents a different digit
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
there are many different ways you can go
i'm just going to explain the way that i
solved it
so first i converted this into an
algebraic problem
i said the blue circle is represented by
a
the gray circle is represented by b and
the red circle is represented by c
so we have the problem abc being added
together three times to produce the
result of c c c
now how can we solve this
well let's take a look at the ones
column
what's the possible range that we could
have
well the smallest value for c is zero
and that would result in zero
the largest value for c is nine and that
would result in twenty seven
so the result of this column has to be
between zero and twenty seven
therefore three times c will either be
equal to c as a one digit number
or it'll be a two digit number that's
between ten and twenty three c is equal
to ten plus c
or it'll be between twenty and twenty
seven 3c is equal to 20 plus c
these are the three possible cases to
consider
let's consider each one
if 3c is equal to c
that means c is equal to zero
but then the final result is zero zero
zero which means a and b would also have
to be zero
and this is not possible since each
letter represents a different digit
so we cannot have c
being equal to 0.
let's consider the third case that 3c is
equal to 20 plus c
in that case we can solve c is equal to
10.
but this is not possible since each
letter has to be a digit between 0 and
9.
so that leaves the final possibility
that 3c is equal to 10 plus c
we can solve this to get that c is equal
to 5.
therefore the final result is five five
five
and we've essentially solved the problem
there's just one more step we need to
take
we have the same number being added
together three times
to equal 555
three times some number is equal to 555
that means if we take 555 and divided by
3
we get abc
555 divided by 3 is equal to 185 so that
must equal abc
so a must be equal to 1 and b must be
equal to 8 and this in fact works out
so now we'll just go back to our
original problem
and this is the answer the blue circle
is equal to one the gray circle is equal
to eight and the red circle is equal to
five
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video i post
math videos that can be watched for free
with topics from people around the world
because math is universal
you can help the cause by subscribing
for free to get the newest videos
you can also watch and share all of mine
your decisions videos which will help
more people discover the channel
you can also email me a math or puzzle
topic at presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you like this video you can also
check out my books which are linked in
the video description and if you so
choose to support that math is universal
you can support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support